warning this episode may contain content
that is not suitable for children viewer
discretion is advised say you love
collecting coins you know so probably he
could talk to you about your coin
collection and just the fact that you
have something you think is in common
kind of makes you feel a little let you
let a guard down you know maybe it gives
you a coin you know familiarity with the
parents saying things like again in a
church setting they may be able to quote
scripture backward and forward that
could actually be a way they grew and
what's so difficult about this is so
many of these things are not wrong in
themselves they're right you know what I
mean or they can be right but the the
good things can be used as a motivation
for the bad thing
foreign
welcome to LED live it's a show where we
use the Light of Christ to expose the
darkness happening in media and our
culture today today we're going to be
touching on quite a sensitive topic that
of sex trafficking a human trafficking I
should say and I'd like to welcome Hava
to the show thank you so much for being
here with us
um Hava has been a director of and
volunteered at numerous anti-trafficking
organizations for over 12 years so we're
just really appreciate you taking the
time to be with us today that's my
pleasure thank you so um 12 years is is
a really long time it's quite a
commitment so I'd love to hear your
story and to know why you're so
passionate about this and how you got
involved yeah
um it's probably not like a really
popular story but at the end of the day
it's just a calling that I have
I don't have any like super serious
moment where you know I'm like a lot of
people will be like I remember the first
time I heard that this was happening I
couldn't believe it I don't remember
that what I do remember is like being
eight years old and my grandma's saying
yeah I don't like to shop at Walmart
they use slave labor for a lot of those
products
[Music]
thank you
but I just remember that as a as a young
child like you know obviously it's a
really clear memory to me but it wasn't
I kind of filed it away I don't even
remember as an adult the first time I
heard about it what I do know is I was
going through a very difficult time in
my life and I live in a pretty
comfortable area
and I just remember feeling so
disconnected from the people around me
the people at church and I started
hearing about this and I'm kind of the
type of person that I like to
investigate for myself and so next thing
I know I'm out on the streets and doing
this and I remember I remember in one of
my trainings they said you can't promise
these women a house with a dog and a
fence and I thought to myself I have a
house with a dog in a fence and it made
me grateful like for what I had and it
was in some ways for me just because of
the trauma that I had dealt with and was
currently dealing with
um in some ways I was able to identify
better I felt like with them than the
people around me and so that really kind
of was a launching point I didn't have
any lifelong goals or dreams at that
point
um I got my bachelor's degree in
Ministry leadership which again was kind
of not
ever my goal to get it in that it just
kind of worked out because I needed to
pay for it as I did it and it was the
program that was available for instant
learning and through that I just I just
kept reading and researching and just
got pulled into it there's been times I
tried to walk away
and God's like nope
okay well yeah that's why messenger is
so important I believe getting people
outside of their bubble to see what's
out there not just for the purposes of
exposure but how they can get involved
how they could use their resources to
impact someone else especially if we're
Christian because that's what we're
called to do 100 yeah so how about we um
let's define human trafficking to set
kind of like a foundation for this
conversation yeah so someone who may not
know anything about it how would you
explain it yeah it's a it's a technical
you know definition is the trade and
let's specifically use the word sex
trafficking because there's other forms
of trafficking that are are bad but it's
just such a broad subject so
um sex trafficking specifically is
defined as the the trade of some some
form of sex for
some commodity so that could be money
food
housing drugs
it could be a wide variety of things and
a lot of trafficking the money exchange
does not actually go to the person being
trafficked okay and are there different
levels of scale so it may not be a whole
organization it could just be a little
agreement so to speak between let's say
a landlord and a tenant yes that can
still be considered yeah trafficking
okay
and then there's obviously like networks
does it fall under different names like
are there pseudonyms of sex trafficking
to mask it or hide it
I would say the term sex trafficking it
has become really popular lately okay
um
and I'm not quite sure if this is where
you're going with this question but it
brings up a really really good good
point sometimes law enforcement will
actually categorize trafficking as
domestic violence
and that is a huge disservice to
actually what is taking place and the
reason that they do that is because
that's the way the funding flows
wow so if they so for instance I have a
um a town near me that is well known and
the people that know what's going on for
trafficking but they don't typically I
don't think their Police Department even
has a category for it they just classify
it as domestic violence there's not a
need to create a category to to help
these people that's where legislation
comes in but that is done at a
legislative level okay so what about
things like would you categorize sex
trafficking as like a modern day slavery
or is that a separate conversation yes
yeah 100 I mean sex trafficking has gone
on since you know a really long time I
don't know where in the Bible we can
actually point in the first time you
know that happened
um but it is I do think it's probably at
its biggest right now okay so you're
saying yeah it's uh more conversations
are being had around this topic but I'm
sure there's still a level of stigma
that's associated with it if you do uh
share any statistics of the men and
women or men versus who women that get
involved is it not so much men or maybe
it's Mormon that we think than we think
and any views about women any statistics
we can share in regards to sex yeah so
that is actually one of the myths you'll
actually see listed when you like look
up and I I encourage your listeners to
like research this like statistics are
so incredibly hard because it's an
illegal it's an illegal trade and so
they're probably not very good so you
only can kind of go with the information
you have and they will vary but one of
the common myths that people have is
that it's a female only problem and
that's not at all true
um one of the statistics we were looking
at just before the show showed that
the percentages of 16 were women or
sorry 16 were boys and 17 were girls so
that's in a child and I do think there
is a definitely
um when you get in the child category
there's more boys than probably men you
know what I mean when you get up
um not that men can't be but that you're
probably going to see more of that in
like labor trafficking but still those
are high numbers and they're really
close it's not like a big number of
little girls and small little boys it's
great okay and there's a lot of boys
with that misconception that could leave
a lot of little boys vulnerable because
the eyes aren't on them right this one
on the little girls yes but is it just
little boys and girls or is it men and
women as well yeah it's men and women as
well
um I believe it was those statistics I
think were like 23 are men and then the
um the remaining which I can't remember
what that number was is about 40 I think
we're women wow is there a
is it fair to say there's a certain
group that's more success susceptible
to being targets of sex trafficking or
is it really kind of across the board no
one's safe type of thing yeah
um I would say hands down if you want to
pick one category it would be low income
okay
um so social economic level greatly
impacts that and then of course and this
is one one reason that like for me uh
illegal immigration is huge is because
people are just they have almost no
recourse and that is known and they are
prayed on
wow okay so thinking of um
you know using the terminology of being
preyed on or being a Target you are
earlier sharing with me and experience
you had on your way over here on your
plane ride yeah you had an interaction
with with a young woman do you mind
sharing that story no it's crazy
um so I had not paid the 19 for my I see
I'm still gonna talk about that
I'm just like I paid enough for this
ticket not paying another 19 as soon as
I see so as a result of that I suppose I
was seated all the way in like the
second row from the back and so I like
go all the way back on this flight and I
go to my row and there's this young
woman she was actually on her way for
spring break so she's still in school
and she's kind of like curled up and she
looks up at me and she says oh I'm so
glad I'm not alone now and I'm like oh
hi and
um I sat down and then somebody else
needed to sit there so and I asked her
what her name was she's like my name is
Judy and and so the person that was
coming he was supposed to sit in between
us but I'm like you know what take the
aisle I'll go sit by Judy and so he sits
down and these are you know we're all
strangers we don't know anybody and Judy
like leans over and says to him which
she's like do you have an iPhone charger
which apparently she had identified that
I don't have an iPhone and he's he's
like sure and I and I look at her and
I'm like Judy you're a teenager you
don't have a phone charger yeah and she
says I didn't know if I was allowed to
have it on the plane and so right away
I'm like this girl isn't used to Flying
you know what I mean like she's and then
later she said um this is the first time
I saw like a meal flight attendant and
so I'm like clearly you're not used to
Flying so she's you know she lived about
three hours from Columbus in kind of a
rural area
before we were just taxing out of the
gate and she like had her head on my
shoulder like wow it's a very trusting
she was just so trusting and so innocent
and and part of me was just like so like
drawn to that in awe of it but then also
anything yeah if she wasn't there with
her headphones on and like not talking
to anyone she's engaging 100 and then
like during the flight like it got
really bumpy and she like looks at me
and I like smile she's like nuzzles up
to me again and you know just like oh
but then these like bells are going off
in me like honey you gotta be careful
who you do this to because because
actually what predators do is they
actually pray that like familiarity is
one way they prey on people right so
like offering a charger or becoming a
safe space for them if the flight is
Bumpy that's actually how they pray
honest she's initiating it but she was
initiating it and so I'm just like you
have to be careful who you do that with
but I will say this is predators are
they have like this radar that they can
and detect when someone is
insecure comes from in stable you know
environment that has been abused and
typically
you know like the way Judy was behaving
I that didn't seem like her background
um but for children or even adults that
are you know would have been much more
common to be like crunched in the corner
no eye contact like and and so they will
prey on on those people and that is a
good point because there's a difference
between innocence and being withdrawn
because from what you're saying in
Judy's case
um being protected means there is a
support system in place or you have
people in your life which might be more
of a turn offer for predators versus
being withdrawn there might there might
be trauma there that they can tap into
and maybe manipulate okay so it's not
that you know we shouldn't like it's a
bad thing to be innocent it's like in
what context
um this person is is living in or
expressing yeah what they've been
through I think being innocent is is
okay but I would say train your children
like just teach them you know what do
you mean by that because someone might
be afraid of exposing their child or how
do you teach with without exposing or
causing an unintended trauma so to speak
um I would definitely let them know that
not everybody is safe okay and you know
at age appropriate levels even give them
examples of that like even in the news
or whatever and I'll be very very
careful you don't want to traumatize
them but you can let them know like this
happened and that's why and then
um really establishing them who their
safe people are like these are people
teach them about their body from a very
young age so that they know if
something's not normal you know you you
ingrain into children just that
intuition right and so you want them you
want them to be innocent but you also
want them to to have in that intuition
and especially in today's world
um because there are predators all over
and they are praying on the insecurities
of children so like the number one thing
you can do
is be
a home and an environment for your
children and you your friends children
that is stable you know I have a friend
who um
her little girl's friend is in a really
difficult situation her dad just died
and and she has this girl at her house
all the time and I'm just thinking you
could be saving that girl from soap
because she has you know she has a point
to go to for Safety and Security and
children that have that typically carry
themselves differently okay okay
um there was a video I saw a while back
that actually became very controversial
what do you do if you get lost
you find a big black guy and what do you
tell him and that I lost oh do I need to
tell you there's a bunch of white people
really upset about that video
statistically based on the data any
child would be safer approaching a
strange black man than they would a
strange white man so let's look at some
numbers convictions of possessing images
of children white people
86 percent while black makeup only four
I'd say white people damn near corner of
the market as long as we're talking fun
facts let's look at this one they looked
at sa convictions from 2006 to 2017 and
you know what they found there was a
1330.47 increase in sentences of black
individuals and a 8.6 decrease in
sentences for white individuals so white
people far more likely to do it also
more likely to receive a lenient
sentence for it is there a danger
in
not just assuming but seeing something
seeing someone and labeling or reading
statistics and and labeling in that way
or should we really be on guard in the
general sense of anyone can be a
predator or is it okay to be like there
are really blatant signs yeah that you
can pinpoint and I hope I'm you know
that's a great question that's a great
great question because that's actually a
problem
um
but Predators come in every Walk of Life
in fact
predators are often drawn to jobs around
children
so you know like that we've seen kind of
an explosion of teachers being outed as
pedophiles arrested you know
um social workers counselors Church
workers definitely youth ministers
um I think maybe the statistic that she
was like referring to is I'm not
familiar with that statistic but the one
thing I guess that came to my mind when
you said that is
you know people do tend to assume that
like a businessman in a suit is safe
okay and that is not a safe assumption
any kind of generalities are difficult I
don't like generalities but if I had to
some of the safest you know guys that I
know they're rough they're rough around
the edges
um they may be bikers you know that type
of thing but they would go the ends of
the Earth to protect a child
yes
um I say yes because uh the stories that
I've heard it are the the people who you
wouldn't expect to go above and beyond
to help whereas Society is labeling them
as a bad person okay
um so
can you take us into the mind of a
perpetrator
and that's a really scary place yeah
because
uh when it comes to how they operate
they might come off as I've changed or
you know it is safe to be around me or
sometimes there's this double life
that's being led yeah so is it like a if
you want a chemical level or is it just
behavioral behavioral and it could
change like when you think of a the mind
of someone who could do this to someone
else what is that like yeah so one of
the things I do like to start with is is
defining like different kinds of
perpetrators because it can vary
um someone who prays on a pre-pubescent
child there's something not right there
that is not normal whereas even someone
who like a predator who assaults someone
that um you know maybe looks like an
adult even if you know it's still wrong
right
um and it still needs to be dealt with
but if they are preying on a child
there's something really really
seriously wrong with that person and
that to typically is pretty hard to
change and I believe that Jesus can
change anybody and set anybody free but
these are typically highly skilled
manipulative people and they don't just
groom the child they groom the
Securities around the child so if
they're in a church and they are in
churches they will groom the pastor they
will groom the they may be the youth
pastor but if they're not they may groom
the youth pastor they may they will
groom the parents they will groom the
teachers and so that it become when then
it becomes you know that maybe the
child's word against the perpetrator
like who everyone knows and everybody's
like yeah we just had it we just had a
barbecue at his house and like he said
all this right stuff you know here's
another thing sometimes a lot of times
they're involved in like anti the thing
they're doing so like traffickers get
involved in anti-trafficking
organizations wow okay and so like
that's a really great place to hide you
know
um hiding in plain sight is is way more
common than people think you know but
but there's a grooming going on and then
the second thing though is you know I
said a minute ago that it can become the
child's word against the
um Predator but a lot of times the child
doesn't even have a voice because of
maybe maybe their home situation again
because they prey on on children that
don't have recourse for a lot of things
but the Predators often threaten them
you know so they will say
um you know we'll in you know really
use this is probably more typical for a
trafficking case but like what could
kill your family if you tell anybody and
that puts the burden on the child to
keep that safe
wow
so thinking about the mind of a
perpetrator they tend to be more
manipulative or they would inject
themselves into something that is really
fighting against them for whatever
reason
um
you were using the term grooming
just so everyone's clear what exactly is
that what does it mean to groom someone
because
um I would assume grooming a child is
different from grooming the people
around them right so grooming a child
could look like here's a sucker what's
your name how old are you do you want to
play with my you know toy set like one
red flag can be
um
especially males but I guess it could be
anybody that has children's toys and
stuff that they have no connection to
children like that's typically a red
flag no connection to children so like
you go to their house and they have all
these toys but they have no children and
they don't have like nieces and nephews
that are there every other weekend okay
you know so it's like why yeah and I do
want to be clear in this because
um this is this subject is such a hot
subject that it it's it's hard to talk
about it
um balanced right so I do believe that
in a sense of proven guilty so I don't
want people to just be like you know
suspicious of that guy's a pedophile he
has teddy bear you know what I'm saying
I do believe in that however
um if they're there's signs like that
you should be watching very very closely
and if there's an accusation especially
like in an environment within a church
or where they have access to Children
the the appropriate people in charge
need to safeguard those children and you
know sometimes unfortunately I mean it's
just the world we live in Justice is
never
um never Swift unfortunately as much as
we like to think but never also accurate
and so to actually get a conviction
sometimes it takes a lot right and so
you might have a situation where you
know you're pretty confident that this
person isn't safe but you can't put a
legal label on them because it wasn't
able to be proven in a court of law so
you still have to protect you know what
I mean and that's why like policies and
organizations
um and churches are really really
important
um and not to judge people you know but
I think it's we have this Dynamic going
on that's so weird to me it's like we're
more afraid of offending a person than
we are protecting a child yeah yeah and
that's definitely a thing in the church
and it's you know elsewhere as well but
that's really why you want to have those
standards in place like you want to have
a policy in place before it happens be
prepared don't just react all the time
be prepared well the other thing is is
like and I'm not a lawyer this isn't
legal advice but typically like from a
live um liability standpoint
like if you fire someone because they
are
um let's say that they spent time with a
child alone like and you don't have a
policy against that
it's harder to have justification for
the firing okay or if something happens
and you don't have policies in place
then you can also be liable for that so
it's which I don't agree with I mean
sorry I don't disagree with I should say
both should be yeah that fall the
perpetrator and the people who didn't do
their due diligence and protecting yeah
yeah and it's also amazing how a little
can go such a long way the little things
that the church can do to protect
um their members can dissuade Predators
I remember growing up my church had a
sort of meeting like that about the
little changes that were going to be
made so every door in the church was
gonna have a window yes especially in
the Sabbath School rooms and where
children congregated and as of present
when we were having those meetings the
doors that didn't have those windows
would remain open no matter how much
noise was coming out of the room they're
going to remain open and huge deterrent
right there right can help so just being
Mindful and aware yeah but thinking
about that why actually I'll save that
for later I want to stay on the topic of
well let me finish your question about
grooming the parents because that's a
really great great question
um but it it's going to to vary by by
the setting
um groomers I feel like are really
intelligent in the in the area of
knowing how to read people
typically annoying like what things
um so say for instance I don't know you
well enough to know this but like
say you love collecting coins
you know so probably he could talk to
you about your coin collection and just
the fact that you have something you
think is in common kind of makes you
feel a little let you let a guard down
connected yeah you know maybe it gives
you a coin you know familiarity with the
parents saying things like again in a
church setting they may be able to quote
scripture backward and forward that
could actually be a way they groom and
what's so difficult about this is so
many of these things are not wrong in
themselves they're right you know what I
mean or they can be right but the the
good things can be used as a motivation
for the bad things
and again back to your question about
like the difference between like what's
going on in a predator
the average time a predator predator
offense is 70.
average is 70. it's 70. this is one
person so when you yes and that goes
back to that's why I like to make the
distinction between
um so like take a guy and I don't want
to just use guys because women do it too
now predators do tend to be far more
male than female
um but if a man has an affair that's
wrong but then it's it's bad but it's it
follows like normal human fleshly desire
right and I so I think there's a big
difference between that when you have
people preying on children that's not
even a normal human flesh you desire so
that type of person is probably more act
to have an addiction to it and not stop
okay because they can't
understood understood and so how do you
respond to that or react like if someone
does make the claim oh I've changed let
me into your circle what can we do I
think like for one thing
um any sin
forgiveness does not mean
that there's aren't boundaries right and
so again coming back to this this
Dynamic we have going on where
protecting children is not a real high
priority across the board in our society
it just isn't but if you make it a high
priority you know you're going to have a
lot of tears and I would say honestly
for someone you know they may have to
accept that they're never going to be
able to be with a child alone like I
don't I don't think that's too far for
someone who offended a child at all I
mean you think about Jesus reserved his
strongest language for that person
like he said it would like he basically
said it'd be better they'd be killed
like that's true like that's what Jesus
said about it and yet we just
are afraid of offending a lot of times
that's a good point wow you know there's
a book called the body keeps the score
talking about trauma and
um the the response of the nervous
system to trauma and the neurological
Pathways that are made that's natural
anyway you know the things that we do
the habits that we create impacts our
minds so trauma does the same so does
the trauma that victims experience in
this situation does it alter their minds
in a way that a perpetrator's mind is
already altered
so it it Alters it not necessarily
um I don't know if I would compare it to
the way a perpetrator like something is
wrong you know with their mind obviously
um but trauma damages a child or anybody
an adult it damages you can have trauma
at any age the earlier it is and and the
um
so this here's an interesting thing
trauma the context of trauma is
typically more important than the trauma
itself
okay also so for I'll give you an
example um and this this example comes
from Adam Young he's a trauma counselor
you have a 12 year old girl at school
one of the older boys takes her out
behind a wood pile does something to her
okay so we're going to take two 12 year
old girls exact same scenario one of
them screams run homes and tells her
parents her parents get on the get to
the principal the boys expelled from
school and stuff like that that girl is
not going to be long as long and is
deeply impacted as the other one who has
nobody to tell and so she freezes yeah
that will live in her and that will she
yes because we were talking earlier
about you know the way our brains are
made there's actual neuropath ways and
um connection their own connections and
they're developed by experiences and by
thought patterns right and so the girl
who has no one to go to
it just replays in her mind and then you
know then she sees that boy every day
and he smirks at her
more neural Pathways and it becomes a
really it can damage her life
permanently and those cases
um that's a child that's going to
typically be more vulnerable to a
predator or a trafficker in the future
there's an experience you shared about
what a father did to to help his
daughter do you mind sharing yeah so I
was speaking at the Lions Club which was
awesome they were like all these Grandpa
and grandmas you know and so um I kind
of like when I talk I like to kind of
you know sense the crowd like what they
and they were very interested in like
their grandchildren like what they can
do and so I was talking quite a bit
about that and after I got done this man
pulls me aside he said I want to tell
you a story he's like my daughter and
he's his daughter's grown you know but
he said when she was in school she was
molested by some of the older boys and
we went to the principal and she said no
they would never do that so there you
have you know principles probably
groomed right because these boys always
respectful to her and they carry out her
trash and you know who knows what and so
she she says they you know they would
never do that and he said I watched my
daughter her personality changed she
started dressing goth and he like
basically emptied out his 401k and moved
her to another state and put her in
another school and and I said you know
what you you could have saved her life
by doing that because
and I just to be clear I do think like
good therapy is important for that
um and I don't know if she got that but
the fact that she she had a dad who said
this is who was tuned enough to
recognize what was going on
and know that what she said was true and
say this isn't right
and I'm going to protect you by this
probably change the complete trajectory
of her life wow that's amazing
um
it's really to start disheartening to
hear the principal's attitude towards
that because she used what she saw her
assumption to come to a conclusion like
oh they're not capable it just sounds
like no the Bible says the heart is
deceitful above all yeah who can know
and so trusting our own let's say
intuitions or what we see
um it doesn't prove right most of the
time and so investigation should happen
for any claim do you agree with that oh
a hundred percent and the difficult
reality of this too is you know what if
there was no evidence
you know like then it's a he said she
said and but is that evidence the the
change within the girl could that be
seen as ever from a parental standpoint
a hundred percent but also from a school
principal I don't know if that would
have been enough for her to get you know
what I mean expelled like and that's
what's really really difficult I was
just listening um I'm going through the
Bible and they you know even in the Old
Testament God says two or three
Witnesses and these people know you know
what I mean they get them alone and so
even even though and I will probably
continue to talk a lot a lot about this
like there's a lot of areas that we need
to do better with Justice because
there's a lot of areas where Justice is
not but there are still some areas that
you know they're not going to be made
right but here's the award in part is
regardless of what that principal did I
must I don't know this girl's total
relationship but just from the story I
assumed that her dad was a very
important figure in her her life and so
the fact that the most important person
in her life responded that way that's
what that was critical okay so you have
to protect your own so for a family
who'd may not have the resources to
relocate or you know they're stuck they
don't know how to respond
who do we go to for help you know what
what can we do to help someone who has
been traumatized who's been assaulted
who's gone through
um any kind of sex trafficking who who
can we go to who can we call for help
that's a really great question
um I I would say you would have to check
in your own local area typically
typically you're going to want to see a
trauma counselor I am really big on like
the polyvagal therapy where you like you
have to retrain the nervous system so
you know if the nervous system never
forgets like that
horrific experiences imprinted on their
their
whole being essentially because it's
their nervous system right
it can sometimes be discouraging as you
just said that sometimes the authorities
are put in a hard position because they
need evidence to to go through the
investigation but even with that you
still think it's still good to pursue
the authorities or to contact the
authorities in every case to to try to
get help yeah seeing Justice served
um on a like a legal aspect can be very
healing for a Survivor so if that you
know and here's the thing if the average
offender offends 70 times you at least
have it on the record
okay that's good you know so at least
you have that but hopefully they'll you
know hopefully they'll do the right
thing it
I have been with victims in the um you
know the criminal process and it's very
difficult
okay so that's uh the one area for for
more of a reaction or a response is to
reach out to you the local authorities
or to get help from from therapists or
counselors or really tap in not just to
the Cog to help someone cognitively but
physically in their nervous system what
about some preventions like before these
things happen what can let's say a
parent or a community do to help the
children to help the people that we are
really called to protect
um one of the things I think is there's
there's an epidemic of in our society
and I think that's why so many of our
children are vulnerable is parents are
so preoccupied that they're missing
um when I had some trauma training I it
was taught by this dear sweet old like
90 year old woman she was amazing but
she kept talking about like the drug
epidemic and how parents aren't meeting
their children's needs because of the
drug and the alcohol and that's
absolutely on the table I don't want to
take that off okay but what is happening
like especially for middle class America
especially within you know just normal
people and even in the church is you see
parents that are so preoccupied they
miss their children so that could be
they're both working
and they have and they're coming home
and there's dinner you know and they and
they're giving their children a good
life they have a great home they have a
great school they have a great
neighborhood
but the children don't have their
parents you know a second thing that's
really really huge is
we already have a generation that have
children now that have themselves been
traumatized and that has not been
addressed and you cannot meet your child
at a place that you haven't dealt with
in yourself and that is huge and so you
know the number one thing is fix your
own issues you know if if you're in
and conflict between Mom and Dad all the
time you know you're preoccupied with
that right get it together for your
children and and I don't mean that in a
unkind way because most of these people
are dealing with their own really severe
trauma essentially you know they say
that
um
a lot of times development stops at the
age someone was traumatized right so
let's say if there was a really
significant event at nine years old I
seem to be stuck yes usually a part of
them emotionally will be stuck at that
age and so I think we have a lot of
parents who are stuck at an age like
when you think about the statistics
um which I think are currently they
change but like like I think it's it's
it's a lot like three to five three to
four out of five women have been
um had a sexually assaulted like it's
astronomical and a lot of those women
don't talk about that you know and if
they haven't dealt with that in their
own life and let's talk about guys too I
mean we heard the statistic about boys
and it's even harder for guys to deal
with it so if they're not facing and
doesn't even have to be that it could
just be
whatever you know but just junk that
they're bringing from their childhood if
they haven't dealt with that enough to
be aware of the children in their care
there they could miss Totally Miss
what's going on their instances in the
Bible of of generational curses you know
one thing passing on from the next to
the next and
um personally I believe that's what it's
talking about not necessarily that it's
that it's God cursing a generation it's
more of the mentality of the forefathers
it's just being passed on from child to
child to child and they're just stuck in
this Perpetual Loop that is just very
destructive to a gen to the generations
to come so yeah it is so important to
take the time to process what we've gone
through in our own lives and so that we
could be fully aware and be able to be
attuned and connect with our children
and to help them through what they're
going through and not necessarily be in
a state of denial so to speak okay so
that's one area the home is an important
place it needs to be a place where the
child can freely communicate with the
parent which is like the first line of
defense so to speak
um what other protections can be put
place so I do like to start with home
because I think that that's the number
one you know calling but I also think
that we need to be going out beyond that
so even think about your children's
friends because they may not come from a
home like that so you may catch
something I mentioned my friend earlier
you know who has
uh is a secure place for her daughter's
friend who's going through a really
difficult time so be aware of that and
then um if I could name one single thing
that would probably deal with
trafficking and and this is just from my
own
years of research and involvement in
both of these topics but
um politics drive this
like politics Drive the trafficking
there's there's a huge amount of
legislation that have not been put in
not only legislation but you know when
the app student thing came out okay that
blackmail thing is real that black male
thing is absolutely real and it's way
more common than people realize even on
the lower levels it can okay
um I think sometimes on the lower level
it can be more like your Bot or here's
the other thing
the the higher level people
they run organizations I was just I was
just um looking at a website and it the
website is run for something
and it's it's
um ran by they want more Progressive
people
in office and so they are they are
actually in in when it means run for
something it means anything right and so
when you have like local government is
so important because you need to be on
your school board
so the policies because this is like the
whole lbgt agenda that that comes right
into this a lot of this stuff that we
all know about right that's more
commonly talked about it's connected
right and so we need to be in you don't
have to have your kids in the school to
be in on the school board by the way
typically you know because here's one
thing
um what I was telling you a little bit
about her story earlier and
I told you how the one day when I was
director I was like looking for social
media to post which turns out I'm not
very good at social media that's okay
I was like scrolling through and like
there's all these organization and I saw
a new one
and they had some story I don't remember
who it was but it was like mom daughter
sister was trafficked and that's you
know so many of these organizations are
birthed out of that and I had this
moment of
we don't have a story like that and just
like that like God said to me your story
is that you should not have to go
through this
to recognize the need
and rise to it that's the calling of the
church yes it is that's why Jesus came
like Jesus entered this world and so as
Christians it's not enough to be like
well we're homeschooling our children we
got you know we have a good emotionally
connected family like everything's good
it's not enough as a Christian we're we
are called to look out for these more
vulnerable and one of the the best ways
you can do that is get involved in your
your local government so even things
like some of it is actually not that
complicated like I'm from Ohio so we
have County
um Central County Commission seats you
have influence all the way up the chain
just in that and it's I think we have
quarterly meetings you know what I mean
but but that actually has a far range
effect County Commissioners you know the
people who control what where your money
in your school goes but in a lot of
cases I don't actually think we're
voting for the people that influence
these policies that make these things
easy and if you start like looking into
policy you will see how policy drives a
lot of that okay well that's why it's a
collective of efforts not just focusing
on one thing because there might be some
level of corruption or maybe it doesn't
work out but I mean you may have the
wrong politician in office but if the
community itself is strong and it's
protecting yes then great you know
that's really
um amazing yeah amazing because one
thing that kovitz showed us was the
importance of local government
because there were areas that like had
really hard measures and there's like
really horrible things going on and then
there was counties that pretty much went
on as normal yes that's true and and
that really showed like the importance
of those really local your local judge
seats and you know all of that kind of
thing and I do want to say this because
um as Christians we have like like
politics is a really bad word and I want
to differentiate between quote politics
and politicians okay because you don't
have to be a politician to like to do
this stuff right but I'm talking about
politics is simply the way we do life
and if we as Christians aren't leading
out in the right Godly way to do life
who's going to take the lead in that so
what does that look like you know what I
mean because
um
there tends to be a little bit of
Oblivion like people are a little
oblivious to what's happening right now
but with the call as Christians to be
aware and to act what does a how would
the lifestyle of a Christian reflect hey
I'm aware and I'm trying to do something
about the atrocities that are happening
specifically sex trafficking
[Music]
um I think
you know one of the things because we
all have limited time right and I'm
telling I'm saying like turn into your
children which takes time yeah right but
when you look at how pleasure driven our
society is how much time are we spending
on Pleasure and there's a place for
pleasure I am not against it that's
something beautiful God made
but
when you look at adults and the amount
of toys they have sometimes or I mean
this is probably gonna offend some of
the guys but like the obsession with
sports you know again I'm not against I
mean I'm from Ohio I have become a
buckeye fan because for my own safety
but you know like just giving that much
like in some ways let's be honest
worship
yeah right that's an appropriate word
and and we have a God who has called us
to worship Him and part of the worship
is obeying him and living like him right
and so and I think that part of the
reason these these subjects are so like
vague it's because there's a lack of
awareness and so here's another thing
this is this is really weird but go with
me here I said to a friend
this guy is he's a CPA he's a smart guy
he is very conservative in Mennonite
maybe even beachy so he doesn't vote he
doesn't have any political involvement
at all
not he's a smart guy though and so I
said I said Thad because I've done this
presentation
um I think it was at like a business
Leader's Roundtable and like people
don't know right and I said that what is
going on like why when when they um when
they started legalizing full-term
abortion in some areas yeah I remember
people freaked out I didn't freak out
here's why
I'm like they're doing it to a live
children why would what it's no
different well what's the difference
perspective yeah right but so I said to
him I said why are people like why is
the abortion issue such a Hot Topic and
hear me here I'm pro-life 100 percent
but it's not my particular calling
although I 100 support it but I asked
him I said why does that like people are
most Christians will like you know land
on pro-life stands with that and post it
to their profile and post outrage when
you know whatever do all the things I
said but nobody talks about this and
here's what he said
politics
he said it's a republican issue they run
on it and they keep it at the Forefront
in everybody's mind I see and I went
you're right
it's so is it a right issue a hundred
percent but I have to so here's where I
differ with in in politics should we be
getting our passion about things from
politics right so my thing is like
our our Christianity our walk with God
our commitment to him should drive
Society it should drive what's going on
so we shouldn't just
take okay so in abortion such a
politically divisive issue right and
that's how they win votes
and again I am anti-abortion
but we shouldn't just be let's just
taking our cues
from them we should be giving the cues
same thing with I mentioned the social
justice movement the church has been so
lack in in biblical Justice that the
world has created their own phony
version and in many cases the church has
just said okay here go let's stamp a few
Bible verses on it we're good to go yes
and I love the church I love the church
but that's partly why I'm passionate
about this is because we need to to
emulate Christ more
that's right
and um think about what it means to be
anti-abortion what does it mean to be
anti-trafficking because it's more than
just words it's more than just saying it
it's also in action what companies are
you supporting that actively yes take
part in the thing that you are anti yeah
just doing that little bit of research
and being mindful of the consumerism
mentality and 100 putting your money
towards and then turn around and say
well I don't have enough money to donate
towards this thing that yeah that's a
great Point that's a great point and we
were talking about Nike earlier because
that's just a really easy and most
people know that Nike
uses some really significant slave labor
in there and yet I mean shouldn't that
affect
are buying not to mention they're like
seriously overpriced but like to your
point having money for low as you say
that in my shoes okay I have
conversation we're learning I have like
two pairs of Nike and I'm not kidding
this is this is really embarrassing
because I'm a girl I shouldn't be like
but like they're like 10 years older one
and one of them was given to me and
they're like my running shoes so so I
haven't bought Nike like ever since I
like learned all of this but yeah I
think that that's part of following
Christ yeah yes I agree and it's part of
who are we serving and just being honest
with ourselves and really thinking about
what it truly is to be something is is
really I feel like the basis the
foundation to then take actions in our
lives not to be um
either in a mundane cycle or just you
know showing up to where we're supposed
to be let's just use Church an example
doing the things that we're supposed to
do on that day during that time and then
we just go back to regular life yes from
day to day no right Christianity is so
much more than that so I just wanted to
make sure I got all of these areas when
it comes to parents and communities who
want to protect their children of course
the first line of defense is the home
but not just within in your own home but
looking out to see who else that you can
help and impact as well and then um
getting in contact with local
authorities but also being mindful of
the local politics or getting involved
in the the legislation process within
the community knowing in your state and
their State's true because it differs
from state to state yes right yes 100
yeah and then of course supporting the
correct organizations and also being
mindful of some unintentional support
that you're quitting out there that may
be in complete conflict to your belief
system so that I get older yeah we
should probably touch on CPS or Child
Protective Services
um child protector like if you
statistically I think it's like 70 80
percent of like runaways and often
trafficking children were in foster care
so okay it's a huge huge demographic and
so that's another area the church can
help I know like in Ohio we have I think
it's safe families and Village families
and they're amazing because what they do
is they go in and they help
um instead of like the children going
into the system because once they're in
the system is very hard to get them out
so what they do is they step up and
they're they'll take children into their
homes like say Mom and Dad are having a
struggle or single mom has to be in the
hospital so they'll actually take the
children into the home until mom helped
and they help reintegrate them with the
mom it's amazing um so that's a really
big deal I just want to put out there
too just about CPS uh know your laws
like know your local laws like like you
mentioned earlier there's a lot of talk
right now about like do you have to open
the door to police you have to let them
in your home find out about that with
CPS because
uh in almost every case that I have
heard where there was like something
like that didn't seem right going on
they let them into their house okay so
and I'm not saying you know don't find
out what your legal responsibility is
there and I'm just going to share a
story if I could sure about what we're
talking about um just to give people a
little bit of an idea of things they
want to be on the lookout for but
I have a really good friend who
um divorced her husband he had abused
the children and she had custody
but he was able to actually get custody
from her the abusive father
and the way they did this was
um through two things one was the
parental alienation
parental alienation I'm assuming she
kept the children away for a reason
because of the abuse so what does that
mean so parental alienation
um is is it's a pretty broad net of
course like what can go into that you
know in this particular case
they told the mother that she was
brainwashing her children into believing
their father had abused them
and so she was causing parental
alienation from their father because
their children were rightly saying that
their father had abused them so
from what we have seen parental
alienation is always used against the
mother now statistically children are
safer with their mother now again you
know I don't like generalities because
there's always those cases but
statistically you know in a in a
situation like that they're they're
safer with the mother
um the second so they took they took the
children completely revoked all custody
based on that and because another thing
was
um she has to notify the court when she
moved and she did but then she moved
again and she didn't get them notified
of that so that was so the other thing
is is make sure you know everything you
know and follow everything to the T
because those are the rules you got to
play by but people need to understand
that these things are happening that's
not an isolated story regarding child
protective service at all like I I know
there's dozens of them I'm in chat
groups with parents
does it kind of go back to the burden of
proof because it was really the children
saying that they were abused but there
was might not have been proof and that's
why the courts were able to do all of
that in this particular case I would
lean more towards corruption okay yeah
there's no like I don't see any logical
reason for that
no legal yeah you know because if you're
going by what yeah the children said it
you know I don't even think there was
probably not even a proper investigation
with proper qualified people to even
determine you know
well to that point I mean a parent could
easily feel overwhelmed with what they
need to know what they need to do all
these targets that are on the backs of
their children all the threats that are
out there so
what would you say it's a parent you
know what encouragement can you give
to to help them through this process of
raising their child protecting their
child and then of course not just their
child but someone else's childhood yeah
I think
um
one of the big things is like we have to
walk in faith and not fear and that's
really really hard when you you dive
into this but at the end of the day
you know I've been thinking about that
verse
um where God says in the Old Testament
you know we know that at the end of time
so much bad stuff is going to happen and
now we're actually seeing what that
actually looks like yes in some ways I'm
sure that you know there's a lot we
don't know but we we dare not forget
that he says in the last days I will
pour out my spirit and what I love about
that verse is it talks about your
children so you think about we're in a
time in society where our children are
the just on slotted by you know an
attack of evil but the promise from God
is at this very time he will pour out
his Spirit on our children
and so it's it gives hope and it gives a
promise and and do you have to walk with
God and I think that you know one of the
problems that we do have is you know
we're distracted we're we're complacent
you know we are we'd rather hang out in
front of the T be in front instead of
the watching the ball game or whatever
then find out what's going around going
on in our communities or in our in our
nation in our world and
um training our children like like
teaching them research has actually
shown that you only have to be attuned
to your children like 30 of the time
like high quality Attunement if they're
in a stable situation you know and so I
just think as a if I was a mom that'd be
great news you know but like if you have
a good setup and then you do give that
just
tuning into your child that can that can
pretty much because the the unrealistic
expectation is 100 right but yeah the
reality is you know they're the eye
contact little things right you can
build up into a great uh protection for
the child yeah yeah yes yeah connection
connection you know if you have you know
trauma I love this definition of of
trauma but trauma is The Chronic
disruption of connection
so if you build that kind of connection
with your child you're going to be
worlds ahead and and I do want to say
this
for the parents out there that maybe had
something bad happen there is nothing
you can do to 100 percent fool proof it
we live in a world of trouble like that
suffering happens but the but God can
redeem even even that software you're
thinking you're speaking to the guilt
sometimes that parents may feel or even
the victims may feel the victims or like
parents like how come that happened to
my child like I thought I did everything
right you know God redeemed like even if
you I'm sure everybody makes mistakes
right like but even if you did it
perfectly there's no guarantee because
we do live in a world of trouble but but
God redeems amen well thank you so much
Hava for being here I I'm wondering if
you have any resources that you can give
to people if they want to search more
deeper into this topic or if they'd like
to contact you how could they do that
yeah so um I would say you don't believe
everything you read on the internet okay
that's good that's a good disclaimer
it's very hard to decipher through what
what is out there
um I one of the things that was really
impactful for me is I read a book called
The Franklin cover-up okay it's a hard
book to read but what I love about the
book is it was written by late Senator
John DeCamp and it's basically witness
statements court documents news articles
and pretty much that's it and it tells a
story and it happened late 70s early 80s
so you read that book and you understand
if that was happening then what do you
think is happening now yeah um for
getting involved locally and learning
more about elections I would go to it's
a 1000 like one zero zero zero Cuts so
it's a1000cuts.org it's really just a
video that kind of shows some things
people experience but then you can sign
up okay to get information and then for
nonprofits we talk briefly about this
earlier but like a lot of non-profits
like are not too good you know that's
it's the kind of a stigma now right now
I would recommend the America project
because I've worked I know some of them
I've seen the work and they're really
doing some of the stuff that like cuts
the base of this stuff so that is where
those are organizations I would 100 you
know recommend support get involved in
for me right now I'm kind of in a
transitional stage so my Instagram is
the easiest it's at Havoline it's
h-a-v-a-h-line okay great thank you and
you know I just want to share some Bible
text here I'm talking about the
responsibility that we have as
Christians
um Psalm chapter 82 verses 3 and 4 says
give Justice to the poor and the orphan
uphold the rights of the oppressed and
the destitute rescue the poor and
helpless and deliver them from the grasp
of evil people it's not for us as
Christians just sit there and you know
pray pray someone else can can deal with
that God we're just in this amazing
partnership or God calls us to be in
this amazing amazing partnership with
him in that we are called to act and he
comes and does the rest the things that
we cannot that are out of our control he
takes care of but he has called us too
yes hey put on your shoes get out there
and do something and scripture does give
us instructions it gives us
encouragement as
um tips on how to do that we should
never feel alone or overwhelmed at the
task that is put before us as Christians
and one more I'd like to read Isaiah 43
because someone may ask you know where
is God in these situations why is this
happening to me and and Isaiah says
um when you go through deep Waters I
will be with you this is God speaking
when you go through rivers of difficulty
you will not drown when you walk through
the fire of Oppression you will not be
burned up the Flames will not consume
you for I am the Lord your God God is
with you he loves you he's there to work
with you he's just asking for you to put
your hand in his and to also be obedient
to his word and his will
so I I hope that this episode was not
only informative but encouraging to you
if you'd like to hear more from Hava
we'll put all her information her
details in the description below
um if you have something that you'd like
to share or question that you have you
can write them down in the comments
section below we're only able to put on
these Productions and also have
wonderful guests on our show because of
your support so please if you haven't
already subscribe to Little Light
Studios and if you're willing to give a
monetary contribution please check out
our website
littlelightstudios.tv or you can find us
on patreon patreon.com Little Light
Studios thank you again for your support
and we will see you next time on LED
live bye-bye
do you have questions about the Bible
that you've been struggling to find the
answers for video Bible study or VBS for
short is a YouTube channel that answers
your Bible questions in five minutes or
less check out these easy to understand
comprehensive videos talking about
everything from what happens when you
die to why does God allow suffering make
it your goal to deepen your relationship
with Christ this year and subscribe to
video bible study on YouTube to help you
along your journey
[Music]
thank you